voila it's a boy wearing a baby belly
inside of which is a boy actually it's
hot water motherhood
who doesn't want to have a baby he hates
looking at me
I prefer dogs over babies I think the
hardest part about being a mom is loving
the thing that's ruining your life
unconditionally and for us as poor guys
there's no way for us to truly
understand what it's like but we're
gonna try
this isn't how much babies really weigh
is it how heavy is this how much weight
should we put into our pregnancy bellies
about 25 to 30 pounds but remember
that's at the end at term what are these
are these baby's balls probably more
likely to stimulate a baby just pushing
into your organs this already hurts
every time a woman talks about a baby
kicking it's like a magical thing that
does it hurt like feels like a punch or
a kick and you know you get a few jolts
every now and then feels like I'm a
marine suiting up for battle I can't
keep my hands off my body Oh already I'm
feeling a strain on my lower back strong
back strong baby I'm already tired I'm
out of breath from wearing it and
talking no it's warm
hey the warm sac is just heating up my
entire body temperature the baby's
heavier it's pressing on things you have
cellulite stretch marks and you're big
it's harder to move around it's hard to
sleep but varicose veins and you get
hemorrhoids what are some of the
positives it's the baby
how much pizza do I get to eat even
though this is very uncomfortable
I think babies are a beautiful thing
it's nice to know that your body wants
to destroy you I can't imagine doing
anything in this like all I want to do
is just sit down it's a big shift your
center of gravity has changed so you
suddenly have all this mass in the front
we're gonna sleep on their sides on this
side nope oh this is awful little balls
are digging into my rib not my balls the
balls in the bag
not my bag let's see if I can get out of
bed
how did they do it isn't the point of
lying down supposed to be to relax
I don't know how a mom-to-be gets any
rest that was the most painful thing
I've done today getting dressed is a lot
harder definitely before I came here I
probably put on lengths for different
dresses and I was like nope doesn't fit
keep getting trapped and everything I
put on I underestimated how big this
belly was my boobs look amazing no I
feel like the worst thing would be
having to buy another wardrobe because
all of your clothes wouldn't fit you
doesn't make my buzzer good what am I
doing wrong why are you laughing at may
simply 15 minutes at eight or nine
months pregnant has been a disaster my
mom she was pregnant with three kids and
every time she still wore high heels I
couldn't see my feet or my crotch that
well so like adjusting my pants was kind
of difficult I understand now that being
a pregnant lady super hard
can we stop no but you can see my balls
no I think it's nice and empathize with
a pregnant woman but it really is like a
complete physiologic change not only
just how you feel physically cuz it
hurts but mentally I have to go number
one or number two you should go in that
side you know I'm just gonna hold it as
I entered from my first my second
trimester there was just the deep demon
like hunger inside of me
Ron McDonald's how come this is why two
orders of Chicken McNugget
you only need 300 calories extra a day
okay I want 20 pieces careful with
weight being we really encourage
exercise
it's 91 degrees outside and I'm
miserable nailed it
once I'm down here I can't get back up
stronger core will help support the
uterus and will help with back pain go
back go back go back
no yoga crunches I am in severe pain
inhale graceful
Oh does that feel like it's bouncing all
over the place Yoga I'm not having a
good time just have to make that big
adjustment it's not my life anymore it's
our life I can't imagine having to deal
with this for over nine months I think I
understood this maternal rejected Ness
because I'm dealing with so much debt if
anybody tries to [ __ ] with me how dare
you yeah but this is just the beginning
I haven't even had the baby yet it only
lasts for a certain amount of time it
really is a beautiful thing and it's
gonna make you appreciate your body so
much more that I'd like such a hard day
I've been trying to with me you try to
my baby I'll get out of the car I'll
punch you in the nuts search trimester
wood BAM it's a baby in your belly you
getting pregnant miracle of life [ __ ]